we're up we're up ah yeah it's the bee
sting King in the rat King bee sting
right yes King in the record oh look I'm
walking at about seven eleven the other
day you know just minding my business
kind of just kind of seeing what was
happening in the area in 7-eleven huh
no outside of it Oh word dude nothing
good happens none of the fun stuff I
don't feel like ever happens inside of
the seven whatever unless you buy the
Slurpee machine they get a little tricky
yeah and you might catch a blow job you
know somebody didn't have a Slurpee
machine worked
yes so I'm out there I end up in the UH
I'm outside in the parking lot and
there's a man a ginger tall ginger and
he's walking by with his child he's a
child another same ginger and no no the
child looked a little darker I thought
you know and I've mixed a lot of things
in my life I don't know if I ever go
ginger and urban you know yeah yeah
that's I mean that's it's sad there's
nothing wrong with it
you know I hear though are you gonna be
able to dunk you know but it's gonna be
I mean you know Blake Griffin this is
what you get yeah you get a Blake
Griffin but you also get a you know your
potato too though eggplant yeah yeah
there you might get ha ha you might get
a stuffed animal you never know so
that's that risk you know but what
happened was so I'm walking across I
walk I'm outside of the 7-eleven and
this - yells out red and bro the crazy
part was there's two other 7-eleven so
they did they think that he was returned
to the gas ended big Buffalo gang game
look at his hand
yeah so I didn't know who this guy was
just for a second I don't know who he's
talking to
you know it took you a while to register
oh and then he drags his kid over the
kid is wearing a Brazilian Jujitsu
outfit right and I don't know if they
call it do you yeah the kid was wearing
a gear and the and they wore
came over and the kid is screaming
crying like does not he's scared of the
Rat King
so see I mean he's probably scared of me
oh they're the real kings in training
boy he's scared of this home he's scared
that his dad is dragging through a
7-eleven parking lot you know while he's
wearing basically a Japanese man's dress
is what that thing is and so anyway the
dude hits me over the parking lot he's
like I'm Rat King and he's like I love
you man his kid is crying his kid starts
using whatever jujitsu moves are on him
like on his leg right just totally and I
don't give a [ __ ] well the dad doesn't
give a [ __ ] yeah you can help me get a
glimpse of the real OG you can tell he's
gonna beat the Sun at the house you know
you embarrass me in front the Rat King
little more funky so that was wild man
and we're just chilling out front the
7-eleven though yeah was looking for
trouble you're just kind of chilling no
I just like to see who's in the
neighborhood man we have a lot like at
our 7-eleven they got a lot of it's a
lot of pimps come out with escorts you
got a red box out there you know the red
box yeah wouldn't you uses those things
do I think honestly women that want to
get or you know who want to risk getting
raped that thing because basically think
about it you're a woman you turn your
back to the entire world it takes a hot
sexy video then you gotta bend over to
get all her dollar you putting your
credit card info don't have the new
hotness there yeah cuz that red box been
sitting there for a minute you know
definitely one of them um yeah it's like
I don't even know if it has movies in it
I think you just plays songs like it's
oldest red bug that's a jukebox
but like they had a UH one time I think
a homeless dude was inside of it and
he'll reenact the film that you wanna
he's trying to shovel through these
brands man jeez which one you say I
can't find it I'll give you a little
nemo and a family man just take that
just as good as the New Avengers yeah
you're fresh off the plane from Vegas
yeah
not to see our boy joy idea shoot his
Netflix special I saw him date it was
pretty clearly minute to Pete yeah who
opened up for him cuz he when i cuz i
opened up for him at the ice house when
he's gonna run a set the week before
yeah that's right i had that video
actually miles haven't even watched it
sure as a watch it
Oh dope and he was saying he said yeah
at all it all depends to I need someone
open up who just brings [ __ ] fire
because thirty minutes you got a pack in
the [ __ ] like yeah I'm guess I think it
was Dean Delray cuz I didn't see Dean or
it could have been Kate it might have
been cake Quigley but I think it was
Dean Delray mmm you know cuz Dean
definitely yeah Dean's a nice guy and he
definitely throws a lot of I mean he'll
you know he'll get people I've been
doing it for a while yeah so he's 70 or
80 whenever I see him we just talk
Porsches oh he knows about horses yeah
you see sell this Porsche Wow to pay for
his throat cancer if you heard his uh
he's got the wildest throat he's a
sellin to buy a house oh really yeah Wow
smart move he's a dope ass Porsche ah
yeah man nice guy that one knows all
like the rock and roll legends but I
think he opened up and then how Joey was
just on fire
yeah man he did good I think you know he
probably uh you know I think he wanted
to get it right you know I mean he was
just and then the second so I couldn't
tell if he was stung you know if he
smoked or was party you know like this
dude he seven death star I can't I don't
know how he functions meanie he's the
only there must be nobody else in his
class and his you know oh yeah Road when
it comes to drug know they say when he
takes like those edibles like most
people would knock out yeah functional
oh he's the bus some rhinoceros
tranquilizers elephant sleep aid or some
[ __ ] I don't know what else he's gonna
do yeah so his first one he was in his
high well he only got shoot two or just
one yet to shoot two so back-to-back
well one and then yeah you do it's like
two different crowds they move the crowd
in and out like I show up no joke I show
up and they had um some dude who just
passed out out front like he was out
front in the line some tall white dude
went down
and I donated probably something are
just dumb as [ __ ] you know because some
people these days are dropping just from
being ignorant that's true you know he
was that was he out in that [ __ ] Vegas
heat that's what I thought too he's like
oh this guy's out here yeah tall really
pale probably go out much you know
probably don't know what the elements
are like no stayed outside a little too
walk in the strip yeah after Eminem
playground [ __ ] it is got dehydrated
yeah I came to see Joey Diaz got a
little too excited yeah passed the [ __ ]
out - ketta - looped up on his own you
know hopes and dreams what time was it
at he went down and he had a black
friend with him and what the black
friend do uh I think he jetted I think
they thought he was gonna he did it so
that dude was gone so next thing you
know I'm over there like trying to help
and they you know they had IVs coming at
a house a mountain do you think about it
no I wasn't gonna honestly even if you
struggling I'll give a little dude
mouth-to-mouth on my giving at all dude
mouth too much
I thought tall I don't know man it just
feels wrong it is taller it's [ __ ] up
man
well I mean I love you know I have some
friends I guess that are pretty tall
we're friends I'm tall Wayne how Paulie
you're not short I'm um I'm like about
511 and a half you know that's not sure
you're taller and kalyn am I really
yeah at all is he yeah he moves so fast
you can't really see how tall he is he
want he does on purpose
oh yeah we're heels sometimes oh really
we had this dude in our neighborhood
growing up named Herbie though we're
these heels do that his own family made
him and they were like three maybe four
maybe four inches high right full shoe
he'll do six months and then he would
comb his hair straight out so he was
like a small person just a book ended
between just things God didn't give him
you know why would he do old was he he
might have been anywhere we were kids so
you get him anywhere from 20 to 40 you
know yeah don't do that
did he was rock your height man how he
couldn't and his grandparents were tall
were little and they [ __ ] and that's
what happens you know you can't you get
them shitty genetics
Oh his grandmother I don't even know she
might have been three and a half that's
all she's busted she wasn't a little
person
she's like a little person but but like
with gigantism you know talking about
you ever see a little person just
rocking that cusp like they [ __ ] go
through it like through the big little
person yeah well they don't have that
fat-ass yes look normal just really
small yeah yeah yeah like not a real
little person yeah but little people
grow all little be like fat asses they
do pH fat not like no yeah muscle to
asses up I'm talking Detroit I'm talking
by glass Pinfield I'm talking pin feel
your pain video ass oh yeah the aw that
ass like you set your screen on the
wrong ratio what's that called
where the zoom where like a zoom out
that goes boom
oh that letterbox like you put it on
that letter ah what you gonna do that
why the [ __ ] would you google the seven
dwarf
and those are senior citizen divorce
which doesn't even really happen that's
a girl see that's how you know it's a
robot myth that's like Brad Williams is
probably gonna die soon and nobody's
really talking about they don't live
long yeah they have a shorter lifespan
you know that's wild man you know some
can have kids and then the kid is born
regular-sized mm-hmm like does that show
little people big world
oh I still love that show man yeah me
too did the Roloffs horse yeah because
the guy I think we wanted to do his own
thing trying to [ __ ] yeah yeah I think
the famous you the fame hit him he
started getting with other hoes
regular-sized hoes yeah once you get to
taste that regular life you don't go
back but then uh the wife seems like she
seems like she did not want any of that
and she still your mom that she runs the
ranch yeah
and he had to dip out and here's a side
piece now and they live in the little
side piece like hut in the back yeah I
promise the same land are you a [ __ ]
peeping tom yeah like a giant if you
show up they will see you in the woods
eating berries and stuff we got an ogre
on the South Pass yeah without mom she
took everything Doug
well you know what I was young minded
yes I always got the vibe from others
she was a good mom she just wanted to
like raise the kids and then he came in
with all you know he always had big
ideas he was always trying to build like
Oh something yeah he wanted to build a
[ __ ] Civil War battlefield or
something in the yard
yeah can't ever chill yeah yeah he was
exhausting
oh he was [ __ ] exhausting on the show
can you imagine having to run your house
I was a little guy running up to you all
the time when I built a [ __ ] water
slaughter you know like a cabbage and
[ __ ] I don't trust him now you mentioned
I see the peas don't trust him at all
yeah I don't trust that guy Matt Roloff
yep
yeah German I think yeah he definitely
does they have a sudden he's just
regular ass sighs yeah they got a son
and daughter and they have the boy zach
is one of them oh [ __ ] you know your
little people big Matt one of them
Jeremy that thing's older brother you
know he believed they were selling
pumpkins dude the biggest [ __ ]
vegetable in the world [ __ ] there
bawling though they did a shitload of
land oh yeah they and they have a huge
farm out there that's an Oregon and that
some people come out to get their
pumpkins but a Matt that that right
there must have pissed the wife off
you're a little person the man runs in
the kitchen one day and says I know
pumpkin pie she's like [ __ ] we know
heavy those are you mean like the
miniature pumpkins like this one nah now
we go in big pumpkins
he's exhausting he's [ __ ] exhausting
and then he's on crutches he don't have
to do any other work he does nothing
hurt he gives around to that John Deere
tractor one else is on foot you know
he's oh yeah he's an [ __ ] yeah and I
think of it that guy look at him there's
the whole family carryin pumpkins and
he's on his hard rock [ __ ] yeah that
guy's insane dude he's at Mom's quad
quad it up though oh yeah she's got that
ass boy she's got that 3/4 ratio or
whatever that is 134 28 35 I don't have
to guess just like 34 34 34 only if
she's nine and look at him what are you
like divided in role just
once you damn did we yeah it really is
do what an [ __ ] yeah he's an ass so
hard in the paint on small people but
but not really though I celebrate him
there's a lot of great ones that I'll
talk about the first time I met Brad
Williams he's been on here on the
comedian yeah I love breath how's Brad
real I know is his boy has been on here
Nick little Nicky no no we uh Jeremy
does that do little Jeremy in a Theo
studio now I think he was it with us
once all the crazy [ __ ] him and his girl
this little they're swingers oh yeah
they're swingers his boy Adam Ray was on
her oh yeah yeah yeah whoo he does the
podcast yep they still do it I'm not
sure if they still do it but I know that
Brad first time I ever saw him dude I
was at USC right I don't know what I was
doing there you didn't go to school
there uh-huh
what'd you do on campus probably [ __ ]
you know perving out but the good thing
is it longer the back dude yeah I'm not
mad at it dude it I had to get my back
waxing the other day some of my top hair
got caught up and somehow that character
and that's called the Holy Grail yeah
when that happens you with a redneck
tuxedo I hope you can hear that's that
[ __ ] redneck taint right there anyway
so you met Brad on us USC he comes up on
a little mini motorcycle the first time
I'd ever a seen a little person on like
a speed wheeler you know or any type of
fast you know machine machinery um and
then just zoom right up and I was like
holy [ __ ] dude and I knew about him as a
comedian I was like oh that's like
that's that guy that's probably was just
crazy man is a superhero
yeah it really wasn't but did you guys
know of each other I know I can't
remember we talked in or not but then in
the future I saw him again and uh and
we've and I told him what that story
he's a cool-ass dude but he's yeah he's
nice but he's a hard worker too he's a
hard worker bro yeah he he was supposed
to come on find the kid something
happened like we're in studio waiting
for him and he just no show oh wow which
is usually I kid for it's Brian's a
little more lenient on it bomb music I
know
aren't you done right stood us up and
then Brian mentioned that to my dude
chops a bit of a dick when it comes out
stuff like if you're late or whatever
and so I was or bride and I were doing a
show together at Brea in the green room
there's a card and there's gift
certificate from Amazon yeah I'm so
sorry
it was his publicist messed up it was in
on him oh wow we're good now I love Brad
that's cool
well it's really nice of no to do that
yeah I don't give me an Amazon gift card
yeah I was weird
yeah I want you just keep that you know
well it is kind of weird to think that
you didn't you're on there shop and he's
thinking about you being on lunch shop
it's just to give another grown man a
gift card it was strange to me yeah
we're like cash like my bad man here's
some kind of sixty bucks to dice because
I was like a struggling comic oh now
that makes sense bro here I feel like
you need it but yes I got it there too
Joey Diaz and it was great man Joey
killed it yeah he killed it did you see
the other comedian because there were
six is six thirty minute specials right
oh wow people shot I saw christina
pazsitzky Christina Tom Seguros wife you
guys know her there she's hilarious
they got big Jay oakerson oh yeah I saw
big Jay to make a big joke yeah BJ's a
nice guy I did I saw him and Christine
his wife and that but I didn't see him
perform the only person I saw performers
Joey that was in and you just went there
solely to see Joey before yeah yeah you
haven't even good to me
yeah I feel like we are pretty close you
know he's uh yeah he's just you know
he's remarkably ain't gonna cry
supportive no I'm good yeah I thought
you brought you to know I got sciatica
brush Hill do you know I got sad get my
tear ducts but you're so that's it
flares up sometimes bro
so now daddy melts a little bit you know
feel whatever son get off my [ __ ]
glacier baby if you can't handle this
[ __ ] drip drip you know drip drip is
busy but I love that man me too he's a
good you know he's just a special dude
good one he is and it was it was just
cool and uh yeah it was just because
it's a it's a crazy night took this long
to get for him to get a Netflix special
because besides that he really he had
like the he had a special on seesaw I
got doesn't count right so it's like for
a guy of Joey count Diaz caliber it's
crazy never had Showtime or HBO or
anything like that it's this industry
man that's what they don't want to wrote
as a timing to write I don't think it is
I think the industry is just so insular
that they only want to reward certain
types of people that they don't know
what good comedy is but he's so
different you know we I know we people
are the same but he's there's only one
Joey did the experiences he comes from
yeah you're not gonna get anywhere else
now like there's a million white comics
ton of black comics this Cuban assassin
yeah one bullet yeah well how like what
more diversity do you want you got a 50
year old Cuban this dude swam here his
mother died when he was young he went to
prison yeah what star is to end up in
prison yes sir if I was Joey
well he might off see it's his
experience but I would have done that
Johnny Cash diamond done my stand-up
from a prison Wow that's what I would do
and I would've shot in black and white
yeah thinking out epic that would be
Jojo you are big joy Diaz in prison
systems yeah and you do it there you set
it up and he would just rock that [ __ ]
place
think of joint Diaz in a prison do you
think it Joey Diaz running a bail
bondsman [ __ ] but it's like a reality
show
no no yeah later a leash and we work in
the back it's like the Pawn Stars but
he's the leader
yeah we just peek out do you guys got
yeah and these kids shows get on my
nerves
well quit watch it a road is a three
time so we'll bring something in there
you go oh god how much you want for it
is 17,000 yeah I don't know a lot about
comic books
you mind chilling out I'll make a call
I'll bring expert in every like three
episodes the same [ __ ] you have you guys
look yeah this is your 19th season you
still
anything and then I don't need the
stupid dumb fat ones being like oh this
is a bad from World War two in World War
two and then they break it goes off
screaming like reading this [ __ ]
biography the best is somebody brought
in like the spinal like oh yeah this is
my grandmother's spinal column you know
how much you want for $7 oh how much
spinal to comb for these days that few
is to chill out why calling my friend
every show every [ __ ] show I'll tell
what I [ __ ] with we're all over the
place don't give a [ __ ] I'll do what
[ __ ] with is Dog the Bounty Hunter oh
yeah Judy em look like brothers
oh dude hey can you met your dad don't
[ __ ] touch me he dyes his hair dude
and he has asthma too and he uses the
n-word so we have a couple things in
common oh you guys look this wife looks
like a [ __ ] yeah it's like her
stomach just [ __ ] hooked to her chest
and then then got a divorce
it just goes are your tits are taking
[ __ ] your old dudes ass on our chest
that's insane don't worry Jerry you
[ __ ] bloated Italian look I got
Italian dude that drowned and then just
still lived take a Persian dude on tests
200 that's staring straight into the Sun
you can't even open your [ __ ] eyes do
I must put quarters in your face bro my
your ass Friday night you and your dad
Dog the Bounty Hunter go get a red box
and
[Laughter]
get some pants for your tits can you see
this life is two hits bro I just call
her tits just and then two toothpick
legs at the bottom like your kid drew it
she looks like a third-grade drawing she
looks like a drawing of a way perverted
kid [ __ ] draw a troll oh my god but
yeah you gotta get him on the show you
would be dude you guys call him up for
her screaming you guys don't have a bat
signal you know a big light with a can
of dip in the air and he'll show up he's
from where I'm from he's from Hawaii huh
that's things from Aurora but he lives
in Hawaii yeah how he's always like hey
brah it's like whoa we don't talk like
that
I'm pepper but he's been there for like
a year or Sony just took over their
language we gotta leave him for tan yeah
people love him out there dude you
didn't get in trouble or some [ __ ] yeah
he said the n-word to his daughter on
the phone one time he called her an
n-word no I was talking about some
animal yeah he said it once and then got
fired yeah yeah I can't wait yeah you
can't have it man his hair is better
than yours oh man that's cool that's
goals though you know I'm saying like
you know his wife just grows hair pretty
[ __ ] hooks it in the back
you also have those glasses like what
the [ __ ] see do you have the same nose I
think do you guys
very similar it just his little talking
about reality shows and I love Dog the
Bounty Hunter
they replay him on any I watch him
non-stop then he must be making some
money or they are somebody residuals I
don't know I bet at a certain point he
probably did have some residuals cuz it
was all based on him looking at those
tits again and get out of the blue to
the blue food go to him with his shirt
off oh yeah damn dog that's her wow I
bet ah I bet he takes crazy dumps too
bro yeah but it's out of a window that
guy's insane
nobody [ __ ] man I bet he [ __ ] already
swims out of the ocean just shits into
an alligator's mouth
that guy's a wild cat he's a wild cat
dude i ah man a good show though if you
don't scene in a hot second look at
titties that's unbelief and hits so they
just call it dog into should be dog
governor that's what it should bounce
and dude if I was a kid I would never
grow up if I had those tits in my mouth
we ever I or or you'd be like six eight
Jack just sucking on them tip at no
those music say those can feed a goddamn
village just one titty enough for
everybody
did you could put out a fire with milk
with those [ __ ] tits there that's
insane I bet she is a savage in the sack
[Laughter]
dude I don't know if I could [ __ ] that
lady man oh you could get them big old
things out slap in your face she started
saying come on boy come on deal come on
son let's do it man's voice that's how
she talks
ha ha and then and then she has at it
she squishing those fat tits but she
can't look he has on those black gloves
she's always wears the fingerless but
has her nails proper done yeah that was
a real problem that's it
all the time his nails are proper like
that 60-year old dude at the gym
business yeah she's still rocking that
[ __ ] did I stock does fish that's when I
first started working out they were dope
can we see her in the pink right there
chin demon and the pink and he's in Oulu
yeah yeah just person they're more fit
into the same liquid and [ __ ] hair
though that is beautiful it's like when
they eat goes to his stomach because of
her titties
yeah they ever do it's like a bipartisan
digestive system yeah there's just one
in the same you know some people
starting to look like their dogs mmm
there his stomachs are look like her -
yeah she starts to look like her dog the
bounty hunter imagine being a bounty
hunter in Hawaii first of all nobody
could go anywhere it's a [ __ ] island
the [ __ ] this is the easiest way to
catch criminal ever a small island he's
lazy
hell I met that's [ __ ] lazy it's like
being a Wrangler in and uh like in a
hamster cage like finishing up pets boy
it's [ __ ] easy man that's in Denver's
a beast for him so he said [ __ ] this was
thank you bye she's bad at his job
you gotta go uphill
I never understood that show like if Dog
the Bounty Hunter he's not a legal
[ __ ] officer there's no he's no badge
nothing that you'll have to stop they
put up with us like [ __ ] you bro no call
the cops you [ __ ] [ __ ] get your big
titty wife [ __ ] these cameras [ __ ] dude
I'm a criminal look at stay confident
sitting me you have tasers how about I
shoot both of you I never understood I
think he gets to be able to look at the
wife's tits and then he get some and
then he handcuffs oh yeah and then when
in the car they give him that Jerry
Seinfeld like my one minute they get in
a speech oh yeah you know you're not
doing the right thing brah you know
you'd only go down this road brah yeah
then he was a drug addict too was he
really yeah so he's like I've been there
brah I've been there you don't want this
brah I'm saying brah to everyone I love
I celebrated man
I gotta watch him again man yeah you got
him man you guys look similar I got to
get back into that we don't look that
somewhere but I wouldn't mind that being
Jack to him the future I wouldn't mind
having more abs oh yeah yeah you might
well his titties starting to stack a
little bit but mmm
but not she just needs to get her tits
out of our face Oh missing Tsar I mean
key wow what is that is that a titty
titty guy I don't know man these days
it's you know you you know there's just
you don't have to pick these days I
don't think there's just some tits are
just correct like I didn't like whenever
they had like a big girl back in the day
and she was like oh I got these tits and
it's like nice just kind of wait yeah
yeah just it's proportionate to the rest
your body rolls it's just two extra
rolls with a nipple on them yeah yeah
yeah you just got way too right I don't
know pal yeah yeah so that kind of threw
me off of a tit game I think her oh did
you hook up with a chubster
um I hooked up with this real tall girl
man when I hadn't really hit a growth
spurt you know so you're shorter yeah
and I would uh and she would [ __ ]
even pick me up dude no she was gone you
she wouldn't [ __ ] me are they saying she
picked you up and [ __ ] you know we
weren't [ __ ] to her children Oh
gotcha she'd pick up from school no I'm
not getting molested by a woman bro all
right what do together big tall woman
you're a child it's all freaking you up
from weird
we went to junior high together dude and
she was tall and I hadn't hit a growth
spurt yet but she would lift me up
sometimes and hug me by at the end of
the day and we kissed a little bit all
right and she had short hair dude and
kids would go out on a school bus and
you know [ __ ] at us out the window damn
cuz they thought that both of us were
boys man ha ha ha
poor girl didn't maybe yeah I felt bad
for us out there felt so bad for I mean
I just it was just you know and it was
just stupid kids you know they're not
per ton Durst a I don't know anything
yeah and that was you know his back when
kids would say stuff just more
willy-nilly but man I fit it made me
feel bad for aa stage like ever even
longer yeah I bet I said one longer
because I was like because she was super
cool I mean she did like a lot of dude
kind of stuff and she definitely did
look like a dude kind of
now that you figure do you think she was
a lesbian huh now you're reminisce
tonight you think she was a little bit
of a lesbian she got me an Atlanta
Braves t-shirt for like our one-year
anniversary that's nice and like a
baseball glove on and stuff so I think
she like I don't know I don't think she
was I think she it could have gone
either way I think she's doing now I
think I can't imagine a really passing a
kid you know but I could imagine or
finding a husband that likes to hike a
lot and stuff like that like outdoorsy
[ __ ] yeah
but they had some money man her family
had some money so I go over there dude
and they had all kind of nice stuff in
the house you know the wild one ice
maker on the fridge dude there's
somebody that I think I would push that
[ __ ] and just let all the ice hit me in
the [ __ ] face and knew it was like
being in it was like being in Utah or
some in the mouth do I go beyond this
you know I'm not even trying to clown
I'm you're not a chubby chaser at all
mmm not really I don't think man but
actually I met this girl in Minnesota
one time and she was big grandiose from
talking cheap I weighed 400 pants were
on do so yeah karate owed 400 pounds for
Latino pounds to those grandioso yeah
elbis and she um painted a person in her
car actually at the end of the day
that's it
yeah that's it she's like you all really
dude I would be sometimes they have
Barra khals on their knee not my stuff
and like their thighs rub together so
they get barnacles oh really
yeah what you've seen my six on pound
life uh uh yeah she might have been on
there no she's had a foreigner pound
life come and she that's true but you
200 more pounds those guy who was a
thousand pounds thousand dude that's a
guy in a kiddie pool died bro if you're
gonna do a thousand pounds bro get the
[ __ ] out it's not fair
no it wasn't fair to him either his poor
Skellington system Oh
dude man that's crazy this is a problem
I'll watch that show mm-hmm then one
[ __ ] l-look here's your belt leader guys
belt down there but I'll watch the show
you get the strap makes me hungry
uh-uh yes it makes me you think you'd do
the opposite but it makes me hungry
like I'll watch the intervention I don't
want to do drugs I'll watch my six under
pound life and I want food oh that's
interesting yeah yeah intervention
scares me bro when they do the needle
shots yes I'm like who is watching this
and the camera crew and the production
crew who was it
who's a girl was in here Oh Jimmy Smith
his wife used to work on that show he
was telling me before he's saying his
wife work not showing Wow so they can't
intervene like that's the rule they
can't intervene the kid do anything so
he would say like she would be on set it
was exhausting first of all but she be
on set and drug addict like man I ain't
gonna make some money I'm going to
target but they they don't want to know
what they're gonna do cuz they film them
doing a crime then they can't hear it oh
really
nope don't tell us well if you're going
somewhere just follow-on don't tell us
what you're doing my ass because they
can't oh we can't do that stuff well I
don't tell just keep it very very
whatever we gonna do we don't want to
know do your thing so that's when they
grown to like Kmart and they come out
with like hey can I like get you they're
all happy like Gang Gang Gang boy they
got televisions and they come back in
and then yeah you got little televisions
in their jacket yeah dude that yeah that
shows crazy when people start shooting
up on intervention that is insane man
crazy yeah I like the old guy who's that
old guy on the right if you don't mind
chin with the UM yeah jeff vanvonderen
dude that was my dude bro he's out alley
cat version dr. Phil oh he's that like a
cat before it's gonna die yeah he's got
that look yeah he does when his skin
starts to just shag on he's been through
some [ __ ] been to the dark arts - that
guy's done so much drugs he's probably
had cocaine and his ass methamphetamines
everything in it every orifice in his
body now he's helping others I've been
doing some acid to his forehead yeah
yeah that stress dude speaking to acid I
had a dream last night I named it ask
you about your weekend man would you do
what did I do
trick questions with Brennan child do I
start taking kratom did you really have
you heard of it uh-uh
never kratom for what make your forehead
smaller no I don't need that now that'd
be a problem something to grow how many
issues you got bro maybe three I'm
actually yeah you're running party's
pretty small in the pool Oh yours is
pretty normal but you have that chin to
ear distances yeah but the thing is is
it's about to run into my eyebrow so I
gotta be careful here how do you shave
that or no woke up like this man
people's me I do my eyebrows too you do
your eyebrows [ __ ] no dude who does I
would get here installed into my browser
yeah I could see that yeah it's pretty
narrow here Hunt's thinning out here
it's thinning out yeah it's not bad
though it yaga my eyes are a little bit
too far apart dude it's like they yeah I
was almost yeah never thought about that
dude what role do you think it far apart
eyes or anything of a toad I mean I
guess I never wanted to think about that
because I never wanted to feel that way
well no I like if nice toad man look
cool like never said I like a nice toad
dude except somebody that's a creep that
lives in New Mexico yeah dude look at
that dance do you see how far as eyes
are like therefore we don't look like
that but you can see your eyes are
similar bro
[ __ ] I can't tell if they are not dude I
came to see pick a different one can
Jesus that looks like yes no I'm giving
you a profile a little bit dams our eyes
are far apart though yours are bad I got
to get my eyes pushed together a little
that see my top or just wear glasses so
it I don't think you have a problem but
if you wanted to like take the attention
off you're really far apart eyes see
that we need to meet in the middle and I
are super-close and yours are super wide
my are close I think that looks like the
hugging like a rat
stung by these things struggling dude
but when you think about far apart eyes
I can't think of another animal I think
of than a toad yeah I think I said never
thought about that I don't see a lot of
toads man I bet we're in your hometown
there a lot of time oh yeah yeah back in
Louisiana you opened the door and saw
some little frog would hide in the crack
between the door and rug yeah it would
fall right down
I love tree frogs really yeah they're
cool I don't really like all that man
and toads are evil man they're from
another realm right guys eat him I know
I've been frog in there we go out at
night and shine the light on him and
then you grab him and put him in a bag
and do well with him so I don't know I
would always go to sleep when we got
back to the ladies I'm in the bag
yeah I don't [ __ ] waimea [ __ ] I just
wanted to be out there doing it I know
but let him go though huh I'm not gonna
step for the next six hours and cut them
up so we can [ __ ] eat them like
something mad scientist's no I know but
just open the bag so they're not stuck
in the bag all night oh no somebody did
something with him I don't care they
don't give a [ __ ] if you let him go or
not they're [ __ ] toads dude look at
him I just have a pet toad really yeah
but mud in a laundry basket in the
kettle he was big brother that is one of
definitely most lesbian things I've ever
heard somebody do that toad laundry
basket full of mud yeah your daughter's
gonna be a lousy human you give her a
laundry basket you put so much a mud and
a frog in it yeah it was interesting for
sure exhibit I realized he wasn't having
a very nice life so I let him go um yeah
I don't know I never had any pests man I
got attacked by one shy animals in our
neighborhood growing up but I was saying
is I had a dream bro that dude I barely
got any sleep I had a dream that Oh
somebody was yeah somebody's car broke
down in my dream right so I stopped to
help out and the dude told me it wasn't
a dream the person I stopped to help so
now I'm like [ __ ] so no you don't help
bush is gone oh I had to help I had to
take him wherever he had to go and then
a bunch of other [ __ ] came up just like
a bunch of just errands yeah we got a
nightmare
oh dude I'm Wiener dream bro I was so
stressed I'm waiting in line
prescriptions I bet no I don't think I
had that answering calls and [ __ ] it's
definitely a lot of stuff on my phone I
had a kid do groceries had to do all of
that bro but I had to [ __ ] this dude to
only because his dude told me it wasn't
a dream so then I'm not like dreaming
I'm like oh like I'm busy
you know I'm your dream man bro [ __ ]
that's a nightmare son there's a
nightmare that's a nightmare it's very
rare I remember my dreams good or bad
yeah I'm very rare I think that's bad
dude I think that's bad for your brain
that's what they say yeah do you ever
think that somebody you know didn't have
brain trauma I've been punched in the
face yeah a little bit but somebody said
somebody sent me an email that said
don't say anything to Brendan about his
brain because he might have brain trauma
really yeah and I felt bad about that
actually
I'm not joking man you don't seem I'm
not sharp because I thought I've CT or
some [ __ ] don't mention to him cuz he
hears it to trigger and a flip-out yeah
I mean that was kind of thing so I felt
horrible man because I thought like you
know I felt no I don't have a condition
yet autism or something I was like
flaring it up you know yeah that's what
I thought I'm good I was like I texted
due back I was like when you look him in
the eyes he seem like he's okay nice
checked out good we don't I don't have
any signs I don't I don't think so yeah
I don't think I do all this [ __ ] if I
did now I might get it down the road it
could get pretty nasty but do you worry
about that no I don't I I think they say
one of the best things you do so because
a lot of those guys are CT and brain
trauma stuff from football and fighting
is they stop like being creative they
stopped pursuing stuff right and then
they're [ __ ] because they're not
really using the brain then it's much to
begin with yeah but yeah is there ever
anything that happens it flares up that
you things like all this could be even a
little bitty like a moment every now and
there anything cuz you know like I'll
forget my keys I'm like well there we go
you know like all right there's CT but
this is your standard [ __ ] right it's
like you forget your family on a
vacation
no never been or you know when he meets
on like oh hey this is Ashley
nice to meet you Ashley litter out like
how the [ __ ] is that girl's name like
here we go it's brain trouble man you
asked for it man you [ __ ] asked for
it
was there ever like a certain like hit
or moment or moment in football or
fighting that you're like oh [ __ ] that's
gonna give me some trauma I mean I've
been knocked out before really it's not
healthy but in football we would in
practice and in games I would know we
didn't know at the time how bad it was
for you but we'd know it's like I'd get
like this ring and I'd have headaches
and [ __ ] this bad man [ __ ] you never
even concussed me dude I got knocked out
one time I was looking for the remote
and my nephew [ __ ] pushed me down
right I mean I think I might have got
knocked down when I was a kid but I
don't remember you know you're a kid
like everybody's knocking each other out
but as an adult I fell and hit like my
temple on something yeah bro and
everything just kind of rattled and then
just went dark bro
and then next you know my brother was
helping me out him yeah you forget and I
was like what was that I thought I
wouldn't hit a warp zone dude you know I
thought I was going to fight Bowser
brought in a what was their son cuz I
never just everything just like you yeah
it's like slow motion and probably
remember much of it that's why I can't
um but yeah I can't even fathom a that
some of those type of experiences you
know that would kind of make me not too
worried about it
I get weary that's what I would I mean
it's one of the reasons I got out yeah
guys stick around too long they have
some big issues really [ __ ] yeah hell
yeah
and they got big fight this weekend
right my buddy was telling right Colby
Covington I'm from a town called
Covington I feel like you and you would
like Kobe coming really you talked about
a [ __ ] Oh does he
yeah hmm trying to think who else is
fighting uh yo Romero Robert Whittaker
CM punk CM Punk fightin
oh dude I saw Pike you up I was at um
well y'all Chicago shoot I thought maybe
you were in at for CM Punk he's from
Chicago I know my mother's from Elinor
I'm a Cubs fan
what grandfather used to cheer for them
and then he died but he um but yeah my I
like Illinois my mom's from Peoria just
some TomTom shoes on too huh loose
pom-poms yeah taking it easy bro taking
it easy
dude lost probably $600 in Vegas playing
the slots brought you yeah play slot I
mean there's a lot about a man hey brah
yeah bro you play slots smokin and
[ __ ] right now you're the youngest
person I've ever met that blade slots
that makes so much sense found out that
I gotta be with the people man you know
most people do tapas in Reno one time
and we got snowed and I was there for a
comedy and a guy died the third day they
found him behind some slot machines do
it playing too long I don't know what
happened if I drinking and that Bulls
playing too long yeah going Lots yeah
you don't win anything
oh no well it's like two six seven
hundred bucks probably damn who loses
that much playing slot hopefully cards
nothing I should have I just got kind of
lost in there and then I sat down and
then next thing you know is what would
you do that night just play slots by
yourself I'll place not play slots this
chick I've been talking to went up there
with me no my lady went up there with
let's dump then was yesterday
so we stayed at Caesar's Palace pic wife
Caesars I don't know she set it up you
know she likes slot she likes lost
he's like slots look bro it makes me
hurt it makes you hurt but I gotta be
supportive of [ __ ] she wants to do you
know lots though so I'm [ __ ] watching
her play slots and [ __ ] for hours
prettier in her huh but I don't drink
drink some reason why you play slots
meet the free drinks all night yeah dude
you just sitting there watching her
loser ass on this boring ass like will
afford to some [ __ ] there's no stupid oh
it's so never ends so I think that
somebody even just being out there in
that environment mess my brain up so I
couldn't sleep hundred percent but bro
let's just talk about your girl real
quick I've never met her I'd have to get
my eyes on her see what working with but
she wanted to play slots and then booked
Caesars yeah regular cafe yeah we had to
go to that Chinese shop nothing no I
don't mean to look at you right out
don't run the Chinese but I don't we
doesn't know the people but I
you know being respectful you know we
went over to the Chinese choice
place a buffet yam URI or something I
think it's called in Caesars yeah and we
went there and had you know cuz I'm on
that paleo diets way to have stuff that
I could have like a soup or something
you know so well paleo you can't have
like chicken and yes I was getting
chicken in bowls right you have chickens
sweet potato you can have your own body
sweat I mean there's not what you can
smell the ramen tastes like sweat yeah I
see him as a kid that my brother goes
you know that's uh but no offense Jen he
is you know it's Asian people sweat oh
that's that's why it's so salty no and I
would see I was like I was like what I'm
do I have an eight one cents
Wow yeah when I was going they said if
you lick the back of an Asian person you
could have like crazy you know be Tufte
and we didn't have any sir he is always
like [ __ ] thought it could be real
you know like their poisonous frogs yeah
you liked a frog Yuen trip trip city
who's licking a [ __ ] frog people do
it bro somebody deserves to die I think
I'm actually going to Shanghai brother
you ever been there no oh you're gonna
China huh I'm gonna Shanghai in about
six weeks yeah how many out there just
for a week yes I'm dude hit me up come
to you some comments a lot of is it like
a tour based thing or he's got three
gigs and it's D it's good money you know
and all Chinese people I don't know you
don't know the detail hope it's somebody
does sign language dude what if is for
deaf Chinese people do they have deaf
Chinese people I'm sure that's awesome
dude you're gonna do stand-up in
Shanghai howling you be out there uh one
week that's a long flight yeah it's
gonna be a long flight so who else is
going out there with you I don't know
your other other comics on the bill oh
no I think there's some local other
comedians you know it's gonna be wild
but it's good money and it's funny you
get to be in China for a week good
stories do you I'm pretty sure you get
stories yeah good stories you can walk
around if you ever heard anything about
China friends went they said it's pretty
awesome I heard yours terrible too
boring
yeah that's heard from my buddy Wow I
don't know pencil chin too if you're
trying to get what weird over there yeah
now I'll cheat bro not on hey well
that's sex every there's so much there's
so much pollution they don't they can't
tell what it's like everywhere you go to
glory oh yeah bro that's one of my
friends said [ __ ] it
yeah China glory hole yeah sushi they
bring a menu and I pull my dick yeah
that stick it any laughs yeah Americans
can do that
that's no Americans can't do that man
you've been reading old books man new
here too updated TripAdvisor you're not
fun though man
do what just bottle of pills you got put
is that cream so you want some let me
see if you're a former addict though
yeah this is a brain riding on a looks
like 36 caliber bullet yeah it's a brain
right on a bullet this that [ __ ]
school shooter pills dude is what this
is what you seen this but you can't have
this man ah yeah that's what's making
this guys people like that do that in
Las Vegas and everything man you can't
Hannah maybe I don't know man crazy
you take these in China see what happens
you should take these in China I'm not
taking those back to China probably what
the price from China this one by some
out then just get [ __ ] weird might
buy a Geisha like cape or some [ __ ] I'll
buy some outfits and stuff but I'm not
gonna get weird them out there oh yeah
one with the culture man that's a good
point I can get fully Chinese yeah I go
full you know don't get races about it
don't ever like a radiant hat or some
[ __ ] like cool like come on I want a
blade like Wolverine or some [ __ ] like
you're ready yeah dude uh what is create
umbrella so not stop talking about that
for a second because just in case is the
last time people ever hear from you I
want to make sure that note what happen
no I've actually chilled out on them so
we're good Jim takes it every day do you
really
I've been taking every day but then now
I'm thinking about stopping for like a
few weeks and see what everyone's
telling me like have you tried stopping
I'm like I actually haven't tried not
calm people take a coffee oh you put it
in your coffee no I take it like coffee
like once or twice that means he takes
it every day yeah
that means this is like a drug had a car
next you drink coffee right well yeah
you know you tell you like take water
would it really you how to drink all
throughout the day yeah
is it a worldly but do you take you
drink water every day I do you take
kratom every day I did it's like coffee
I said it's not coffee that means that's
all addicts excuse right yeah that's the
thing yeah that's why I'll give it a
couple weeks off just I want you to do a
cold turkey right now I already took
some this morning Wow what you waiting
for that I'm gonna wake up once you do
tomorrow me yeah start tomorrow
let's start there tomorrow guy be on
wedding scratching your neck if you
can't do it it's like if it's struggled
city lettuce no chin I'm not seeing them
interested to see what happens Wow I
Jenna suddenly a lab rat for DFAT
yeah I love this dude you gotta get him
one so crazy so you stop taking it right
you said I took it this morning bring up
another picture jeff vanvonderen please
from intervention
you should get Jeff man Roger I'm here
asking about kratom well just to talk
about supplements and now people can get
addicted to those I bet he would have a
ton of story
yeah he would be fun dude that got me a
funny dude Holly holes fighting this we
need get on before he died yes well he
just yeah I know he did that he had that
gig with monopoly for about 20 years and
then he was helping people recover from
dope
he's gonna I'm sure run work at the
front of a train for about eight months
and then he'll die and that's probably
gonna be unfortunate because all the
people in the intervention all the
therapists are former addicts huh yeah
that better and everyone - yeah they're
only better than people who are addicted
that's it
it's one step but they throw that in
their face I've been there look at me I
did it all again look at my life all
right bro you got a [ __ ] suit on you're
obviously here I don't want that for my
saying they're not bad people they're
helping people change it up cocky as I
tell you don't say like that's a guy see
nuts without intervention the real cocky
about it
shooting heroin into his nose okay they
gotta be cocky about Oh shape oh no I
don't like how they feel that shooting
all the addicts face though you know I'm
saying they're not like you gotta be
willing to cut them off kick him out of
the house no money mom are you ready to
do that like [ __ ] no that's my son you
[ __ ] and then they all go to a Radisson
and have a big free-for-all was at a
Radisson Ramada oh yeah it's usually
like you're right the Reston Ramada Inn
sometimes motel 6 depend on the guy oh
dude
motel 6 6 6 but people get gunned down
at those all the time Ramada has the
murder rate at Ramada is unbelievable Oh
Ramada it's either murders or you dick
son there's no in-between
dude the third-floor Ramada always
closed for murder bro there was always a
murder it's always there's no more
that's where you go dude they had a mint
on my pillow one time I thought it was a
[ __ ] grandma crack no damn good see
that's a gift yeah chin is a drug guy
though
were you really if no yes no he is how
are you even taking kratom everyday
probably a year and a half I always
looked at it like coffee so that's the
problem
research believe me a ton of research
because I don't wanna take prescription
drugs right because I know those are bad
right yeah this is natural and what is
it natural from what the tomato it's a
leaf so the coca plant leaf nobody has
ever hurt hook dude yeah both you guys
are on kratom there's I crushed leaf
that's bro that's [ __ ] you can't take
nothing for us crack bro yeah I'm
straight well yesterday I did it though
and the day before
I didn't yeah sure I promise I swear bro
yeah I swear that's probably just the
kratom talking there but you can't take
nothing as a former addict huh I can't
take much dude but what's crazy is if
I'm even around like a couple of weeks
ago I was like talking to this oh I gave
a girl a ride
he'll who worked at The Comedy Store
something she been drinking vodka you're
not gonna sell the mallet on her [ __ ]
breasts are strong and it turned you on
I don't know if it'd turn me on it made
me remind me of lightness yeah reminded
me like some busted chicks I'd hooked up
with wild days but it made you thirsty
for vodka no all what I would prefer is
cocaine that was your drug of choice
dude I would have a glass of cocaine if
I [ __ ] y'all milligram from from [ __ ]
deep bro yes Steph Curry of cocaine yeah
yeah I'm step for point shot um that was
your drug of choice is coke yeah I just
liked it man and then I'd be at home by
myself doing it and I didn't I didn't
even do it for long and it just happened
like but it escalated pretty quick just
coke tour you never went to anything
else I never smoked any crack I kind of
wish I would have you know just see how
it is yeah it hurt here oh one is the is
the [ __ ] oh dude that's the [ __ ] six
flags of drugs bro Six Flags but you
could stay wherever you are
yeah the park park HAARP hopper yeah our
copper drug yeah he's just fun everyday
everywhere it's not it's out and it's
never yeah that's what I think of heroin
I won't try it though but here's the
thing man would you try for you die yeah
oh yeah that's what Doug Stanhope says
so he's gonna try it right before he
dies
yeah okay that's my kill him yeah I know
or you're gonna be so addicted to it you
know you're any death baby my damage it
was sick dad yeah just got to experience
it you know dude if you died on heroin
that might be the way to go anytime I
like Kurt Cobain or some [ __ ] yeah like
I'm just wondering man I was thinking
the other day when you die like your
soul is gonna be like with all these
other souls like there's gonna be
caveman souls like it's gonna be sold so
all throughout time so some souls you'll
be you'll meet and you're like oh this
souls a [ __ ] idiot
right you know [ __ ] yeah this is all
like there's no books in whatever world
we're moving on to yeah and also some of
the souls aren't gonna be as enlightened
probably maybe it'll be more enlightened
if they're from the past true because
maybe they because they can look down on
us
yeah learned maybe like oh wow you guys
had so many beautiful elements out in
the world you know and you guys ended up
just you know playing a Sega all right
you know in Sega yeah you religious
I mean I believe in a higher power you
know I mean I'm not a [ __ ] out here
I'm not just working out here working
freelance brah you know yeah and then
you die and that's it no I agree
I'd rather double down on the Lord bro
you don't say because even if it doesn't
exist what do I lose I lose nothing
knocked at least in the club yeah you've
heard of a hedge fund dude that's all
this is bro yeah this insurance really
life insurance yeah after life and yeah
after life insurance do you look like
something would sell after life
insurance no you look like to me it
hangs out around caskets bro it's all
possible left on my backyard I thought I
can't believe feel doesn't have laws
like that there's certain annals that
just go with other people like dude I
feel walk just put my like I just raised
to stretch in the morning there's a
possum hanging from under my arm like I
would be surprised if we surprised you
at your house was like I don't know some
sort of cool breakfast and like I woke
you up me an opossum your bed and
doctor's wife so then big tick later
that was surprising at all cuz you're a
younger version of dog just trying to
[ __ ] dude if I couldn't have imagined
having this big tits dude taking that
bra off it would be like doing those TRX
fans at the gym dude can you imagine the
pressure you would have to have to push
those two bra is it together to get it a
snap over oh I don't have the stress and
then that thing whips out [ __ ] eyes
that's what's impressed about dog the
bounty like he is is strong enough to
get those tits out of those cats
he's like Sisyphus or whatever who's a
Greek person who pushes the boulder up
the hill but never gets it there I don't
know you went to old school man dude he
could [ __ ] put those tits on his back
and do ya you deadlift those teasers
you've been down yeah yes swole that
prison worked out with his girl man
Sisyphus Sisyphus there you go dude
constantly pushing the rock up the hill
dude in this room ahead wanting Joey
Diaz
jokes from the other night he said oh he
never come harder than when he started
eating protein powder and doing squats
for two weeks
the place is going crazy oh it was great
once it come out does he know I'm not
sure I bet the turnarounds probably a
couple of months you think yeah and
they're gonna release all six on the
same time yeah I think it's just
yet--it's I called the half-hours how
they do it now is I think some people
get tired of watching an hour I could be
on some of my favorite comics
I'll watch an hour I find myself gazing
in and out of yeah I think be like
what's he time I'll um these are my
favorite guys yeah - our makes sense I
agree it's almost like a bit you just
want to see a bit yeah yeah I agree and
then also I think you feel a half an
hour you if we start gravitating towards
more that way you could have more
specials yes like damn field drop three
half an hour's this year yeah and then
also as a comic as a business man you're
getting paid for all three of those
specials yeah just one hour that's a
good point dude I want to start with
focusing to learning more Spanish so I
can I want to do a special in like
Spanish yeah like in Nicaragua or
something my dad's from Nicaragua it's
only to do special in Nicaragua yeah dad
is not Nicaraguan
ah we might have to edit that out there
because that time closer okay go one
more time but I want to see how racist
this is uh make a wrong win well bro a
couple of guys just shut up at the door
dude you can't even speak on kratom can
you you say it Nicaragua yes broke my
father's from blue fields Nicaragua blow
lisinga rocks why do you know I'm not
your Hawaiian and bad get over your bed
okay you for real though your dad's
would make a wrong yeah I'm polishing a
rock oh man somebody [ __ ] on a boat to
make me yeah yeah I'm done
yeah I'm not I'm not a lamb baby bro oh
but that's one of my life goals is to
learn enough Spanish to be able to do a
special in Spanish I feel like that's
gonna take too long
you me 7d but you know hard is learn so
my girl is Spanish her mom they're
straight from Mexico oh wow my entire
house and the TV's Spanish all my son
understands Spanish better really I've
been around it for five years now
I don't know [ __ ] I know that nuts dude
that's you dude I know I don't like an
pick up a little bit but as far as
[ __ ] speaking it in a comedy special
betting for you so any other man whose
wife and child speak Spanish would know
Spanish okay no you're basically a
babysitter's which you are dude no it's
like I'm an immigrant
no it's like I'm on some work visa and I
don't work out in your own time to pay
the bills
you know the gringo who pays the bills I
don't want [ __ ] tostadas every night
I know brought you in frustrating is it
really no but Latinos have the Bamie bro
just the way that they took six
ingredients mix and Minden 900 different
ways that's the best at it right
everything's the [ __ ] same just
shaped different the burrito if you
really think about it double decker taco
yeah the double decker taco is a gordita
this added the tortilla to the double
deck what about the new Australian
cheese boomerang you just throw this
thing ie you throw it it comes back in
lands right in your baby's jaw feed the
whole family that brought that right we
have to edit that water Molins when I
was growing up as a fruit bro so you
talk see to you that's fair and that's
why you don't speak Spanish man yeah
you're right man
but would you learn Spanish I took
French for four years advanced French in
high school advanced friends I get
British on the croissant hunter yeah
Doug
dude I could see you at a bakery at
night just hunting croissants bro
are making delicious chocolate
croissants yeah what a [ __ ] creep
do you look like this you look like the
guy who sell pig in a blanket that guy
I definitely look I love peeking the
blankets dude you look like the biggest
dude on the little league baseball team
that's not good at baseball
like dude good thing we got Ernie and
then you [ __ ] go to the first game
and Ernie [ __ ] sucks bro they put him
in the outfield but past the fence like
just to watch the car the guy would have
tic tacs in his pocket but not in the
box oh just like late on them like I
guess I'll take on these mints you look
like you Jack out there who's the boss
Bob why these tic tacs wait a little
little sweaters detect that a fruit shop
do I love orange tic tac though man how
good are they
it's not a mint that's a [ __ ] candy I
mean I breath better I don't know if
they make your breath better they make
your mouth orange and they make you seem
like I think of anybody that's eating
them on the regular deaf it seems like
you know crazy yeah they're delicious
though they're delicious but that's a
problem you eat 14 at once and the whole
box at one time yeah are bad either
I don't do anything Riemann's are
discussed all the green suck dick
oh they're mint tea and they're kind of
but see those are for your breath but
the orange ones are just for fun yeah
but dude I feel like you if you're
eating those you probably seem like an
adult that's still willing to get
molested you know to tell somebody
you're young yeah yeah it's a good point
yeah I don't have any friends we eat
orange tic tacs like on the regular I'll
eat him at home I want to eat him out in
the wild that's where I were you if
someone gave me something like a gift
bag or something I'll eat them but I'm
not gonna buy or purchase my own
fly the [ __ ] dubby or they still the
defending champs cubs I have a zero
No whatever who won dude the last series
yeah
the Dodgers right or was it Minnesota
are they wanting no one comes one 2016
you know Dodgers one dude they're on
roids - the Dodgers are don't act like
you're a Cubs fan now go Cubs go bruh
dude Andre Dawson dude you know I'm
saying Ryan Sandberg son Marshawn
Dunston what's up okay okay you want
Mark Grace then I will go Rick Sutcliffe
oh [ __ ]
all right you can crazy Sammy Sosa did
he play for him look you know Jim while
I'm thinking about he's white dude I was
black Sammy yeah he's gonna paint no
he's white yeah he's like a salmon color
now yeah well I think they're trying to
his yeah cuz I think surgery's he got
that white people surgery I wouldn't say
that the white people wear it is I swear
it's from an interview go what look at
him and his girl he's uh he's scary now
what happened you'll get that oh wow if
you saw that in an alley selling the
orange tic tacs you would [ __ ] your
pants wow he looks like a alligator I
think that this is a byproduct of having
you steroids and stuff absolutely not
they say it's a mental condition how he
wants to be white so bad oh really it's
white appropriation I don't believe it I
believe that this could be something
from using steroids a lot it makes you
question yourself makes you feel like
you know alters yourself a little bit
and I think it's the Michael Jackson
thing I think he you know he was born a
cuban black man and was that wants to be
white so bad he wasn't finished
operations he wants to finish as the
joker it looks like Michael Jackson was
an Asian woman by the time he died if
you go I do want to read honest yeah
only person that ever did three races
was Jackson I think you might be right
so she literally turned in a toad
that's a human toad Wow if I could lick
his uh if you lick his uh whose back of
his neck yeah yeah if you look if you
look at the back of his neck you wake up
in Beth's tits yeah how crazy is that
one just one to himself white one of the
greatest baseball players all-time yeah
definitely man yeah but I would go of
smen spend my summers up in Illinois
[ __ ] everybody loved the Cubs and
they hate of the Cardinals I was a thing
Wow who is that what is that why where
are they
why are they in rehab wait here it's a
beautiful sunset I'll give him that in
the bath these aren't real people man
who's gonna win that Holly Holm fight do
you think against Megan Anderson yeah
it's a tough fight man Holly should win
she's the favorite but that Megan
Anson's no joke I think I picked Megan
dancing on my show yeah but most people
think Holly's gonna get it done all he's
lost her last four out of five no son
some suspect wins and losses but still
that's crazy man this is a good ass card
man yeah people are pretty excited you
think CM Punk has any chance I do that
might Jackson photographer yes yeah oh
you could beat up a photographer did I
see it happen although every day on TMZ
all the time Bieber hit the [ __ ] yeah
and they don't do [ __ ] this is very
similar they have a common opponent and
CM Punk lasted longer oh yeah yeah them
boys should not be on the main card but
it is what it is
yeah that's brave him for him to go from
rest I'll think I was at the wrestling
thing one didn't even like its come out
on route of WWE event and say he was
gonna do I think so are you dodo do you
fan um I like some of it man you know I
like a lot of the older stuff I like the
guys with the more mental health issues
now and stuff yeah back when these
droids and stuff like that you know they
still do but probably different kind now
higher-grade
I don't know a little more knowledge on
it like I feel like Hulk Hogan was
taking [ __ ] handfuls of pills I had
no idea what was going on
yeah do you think that will ever get to
a place where you can take a pill that
will comfortably make your body like the
same that steroids you know did for
people 15 years ago oh for sure well
there's pills you can take that are
steroids right but it's harder on your
liver so that's why people inject it so
do you think they'll be something that'd
be easier on your liver
that's what Honoria I'm sure like one
day be sure to look like he minute I'm
sure it's out now Wow what's I'm gonna
be a thing where everyone just looks
like [ __ ] yo Romero you know they
look like teenage Ninja Turtles just
shredded but do you think a lot of girls
don't like that I feel like guys only
get big
for other dudes yeah no I'm saying like
most girls are like oh I want him as big
and juicy as possible shredded are you
really doing it for other dudes yeah
yeah yeah at a certain point yeah it's
kind of a yet it's kind of become a you
want to impress your buddies kind of
thing yeah it's like an ego like a bait
like I want to be jacked man where if
you ask the girl she's like mmm
not really my thing not as much it used
to be more popular like the Jersey Shore
thing yeah I think be I think in those
areas is still pretty popular you know I
mean I'm also a weak dude you know like
I used to be strapping oh yeah you know
I used to be jacked bro but I and I
loved it man you know I mean the most I
got immense was maybe like 245 or
something okay but but now dude I can't
even know the weights just got so heavy
they need to make lighter weights you
know I'm still lift lighter you know
yeah but I work out oh brother
not right now did I do yoga brah and
it's definitely pretty sketchy with a
tofu body oh yeah soft dick I can feel
my [ __ ] dick getting soft around the
sides yeah
probably produced a lot of estrogen [ __ ]
I don't know you know your girls not
complaining though so don't matter
yeah man healthy and I don't do you know
I'm not a big I'm not a big sex guy you
know I like to [ __ ] more just come in
my dreams you know you don't want to put
the sweat you know I workout and sweat a
lot of times people [ __ ] at nighttime or
[ __ ] around maybe mid 1 p.m. yeah not
now you know cuz I'm at work but but I'm
yeah let's [ __ ] during the day why is it
late at night
yeah and then also you get my heart rate
up it's been hard for me to sleep yeah
yeah it's like dude now I'm all [ __ ]
jacked up I got come on my stomach yeah
one stone
yeah now mister rest you know on you
know on your you know on your lady's leg
or whatever somewhere in the house yeah
I'm with you man it makes more sense
during the day or mid-afternoon to wake
me up and how do you think you seem
feels yeah you get tired dude yeah look
you already look tired and uh probably
good tired
and you look at your talking on the
phone a night to your dad about the
honor tell you tell you how not to say
the n-word on Today Show
are you okay tell me the that sleepwalks
but is happy about it that's you see you
always smile with your [ __ ] eyes can
you smile and open your eyes at the same
time Betty you can't bro Bechet you
[ __ ] can't do it to fro me or change
it I can make ya'll laugh and steal
everything in this way [ __ ]
what do you see me dude you guys are out
of your minds man out of your minds but
bro are we just talking about you had
some curtain fence tchen yeah I got a
few the first one is the Miss America
pageant see this [ __ ] deal yeah they're
saying bye to the swimsuit competition I
mean no one's watching this [ __ ]
anyways right however like how you gonna
say that what we're doing there take
advantage of these women when they
signed up for a beauty pageant you know
they're getting rid of beauty pageants
there's not a beauty competition really
yeah so it's like but what if what if
some of these young ladies like that was
their strength being a bikini and like
well now nowhere to me more relied on
their talent and personality all right
so you're talking about a shitty [ __ ]
America's Got Talent
I'm not watching that I like in the
first place but I'm sure as [ __ ] not
watching these hoes play [ __ ] a
Spelling Bee now like it is what it is
yeah I don't wanna watch Tanya juggle
you know what I'm saying like you why
and what about the girls that are
trained for this for so long away from
them Oh what happens to the bad [ __ ]
who are bodied up and like wait till
this bikini think oh oh you gave that
good answer in the beginning about
American politics wait till you get the
bikini that's my [ __ ] yeah these tits
and ass out we'll see what's up Jamie
yeah yeah no that's gone and now this
[ __ ] has to learn to juggle she has to
learn some sort of trait she doesn't
have you so we had a half-assed product
this is like CM Punk and Mike Jackson
finding the UFC really yes it's a bad
process yes well I know see him function
wrestler what is Mike
he's a photographer you said yo yeah
he's a photographer so yeah like a
painter huh
no I'd be more concerned for steampunk
if it was the pain yeah
but you have photographer verse a guy
with zero zero experience
oh dude but you got them flash balls
over here too went that [ __ ] flash
bulb and stun light and then [ __ ] on
your fingers then develop some that's
his finishing move with the develop
developer CM Punk just [ __ ] laying
there just you know in a sixteen by
twenty [ __ ] leg lock I don't think
you ever see any of those gentleman
fight again just like you never see most
these girls compete this competition
[ __ ] up okay I also think it's here's
what I don't like I don't think like
it's that we make it oh a woman can't be
pretty that that's a bad thing you know
I agree this thing where it's just ugly
women writing articles saying that that
because they like to write that they
that they want to bring everything down
that's about looks I don't think it's
fair you know I don't think it's fair at
all like no one's forcing these girls to
enter a beauty competition no one is
they enter it because they look a
certain way that is appeasing to the
people's eyes yes and then they wanna be
like I'm so appeasing maybe I can win
some [ __ ]
yeah that's other very pretty women
right no let's make this more about
brains well well I'll watch a spelling
bee
yeah then go on Jeopardy but I'll go on
a beauty competition yeah are all watch
spellbound you know and imagine the kids
are you know wearing swimsuits we're in
yeah but here's the thing you could get
though you know you could get women who
aren't maybe some of the wisest ladies
doing unique talents all of a sudden
because they have to learn talent on the
fly I'd be so terrible to watch be
terrible but how great or I'd put them
in their bikini and put helmets on them
ramming each other like ran and then see
who just with that you want ratings or
not bro but I would love to see a chick
who just learned how to do the shell
game you know that thing yeah here
over here yeah like shitty magic yeah
you can see your like hide in the car
also the thing for me is this was like
the reason you have all the different
things is it doesn't just go to the
prettiest girl and it doesn't just go to
I think people are more accepting of all
types of body types these days and you
could still have a bigger girl or a more
rubenesque lady in a swimsuit
who gives a [ __ ] dynamite answer who
do made herself look nice in the
swimsuit who [ __ ] wins the thing like
Beth could win this thing put her tits
you know and I and I bet people would
like to see Beth no Joe you ripped that
answer and be sick bro America yeah bet
no because her anus yeah what do you
feel about the foreign exchange program
and the underserving and kids are
starving in people to the moon for the
first time and she and every watch one
of those tits on Tim yeah boom place
shuts yeah
checkmate and checkmate you all right
this is a paraglider oh I thought that
was [ __ ] a lawn mower so he paraglide
it and fell into a forest and then check
out what got jammed into the Sun bar
stole into his shoulder
Oh higher tree Brett like the the thick
part of a tree branch that's real damn
so Robocop and the guy he was like
having fun with it
check this thing on they blurred the
images of course how these not it's just
like passing out dude see I saw is that
kratom maybe you might be on creative
yeah you might burn crazy love that dude
how crazy this is see this is gonna all
these kids gonna start doing this now
putting wood into their bodies and
putting treatment in the body to those
to hurt like a [ __ ] ah yeah they
have that one thing when that guy got
hit by that javelin and that looks scary
where and one of my buddies was running
one time in a Japanese restaurant cuz
somebody said it was on fire and fell on
a chopstick what
and if [ __ ] laws right between two of
his ribs that's right mmm oh I don't
know probably most of my let me think oh
do when I was born
or whenever I was like a child I had a
my wiener hole was too small and they
had to cut it to be bigger bro dude no
joke bro I could [ __ ] piss and wash
your teeth from here chin not even
joking do not what you it would look
like a Chinese star like that just
thinks I just star coming out yeah
starfish dick [ __ ] starfish it's a
[ __ ] a little I know but your hole is
like a starfish let's make slits oh no
no they didn't like and turn it and I
can fancy shape it you have to hey it's
just cookie cutter stark you can't it's
like missing a Christmas tree or a
jingle bell shape no it just was so
small that when I would pee it would
just shoot and there's some syndrome
it's called where they have to make it
larger so I remember going into the
hospital how old mm-hmm probably seven
damn though we can fix it
earlier than that they don't remember I
think we didn't have insurance or
something you know she had to just
[ __ ] piss far for a long time damn so
you wanted even got that dick done dude
I got a big job I guess I did it rather
just the tip just the tip dude yeah
urethral stricture treatment damn bro
you're born a small dick hole yeah did
it hurt when you pee big dick baby hole
that's what they called me at school
baby hole damn
oh did it hurt when I peed that's the
promise started to hurt mm because my
lot of horsepower trying to come through
that little hole oh dude it was like
trying to get a million people just into
an anthill you know oh yeah yeah man and
it would fire me and I could [ __ ] I
mean it yeah you could probably take out
spray oh yeah but not you it's super
soaker day like you if say if I did it
on to you you would feel like somebody
was just Gleek and on you like it was
this lightest stream bro so it would
take me seven eight minutes to piss you
know oh my god exhausting I hated it
didn't then the crazy thing was I
developed this thing I was urine are you
wet the bed I was almost probably 31
damn because of that I just had severe
anxiety I was just like in my sleep I
would just be super nervous and then I
was just urinating so much bro
when I was younger I went to bed three
times the same night I'd have to get up
change my sheet and here's some problems
child it was that was exhausting I think
I was exhausted our time is probably 11
you looking tired yeah but nothing like
you or Fox tired from life no stop oh
dude I was working nights I felt like oh
you're worried you have no time off I
had a job missing every other [ __ ]
I'm in bed with you to start for his
dick you get no rest
thank God it's fixed man thank God when
they say can flare up again brother
already not you probably shooting ropes
a silly string
dude you could definitely bro you could
wash somebody's ear lobe from about 11
feet away dude so light too they would
think maybe just uh you know like uh
just like the small like a tall insect
came on him off of a tree burger zag
leaked on their elbows quick mm a one
Dana Wyatt was talking about getting rid
of the early morning weigh-ins and going
with the regular ceremonial ones those
would be the official weigh-ins and so
many people are missed in it yeah yeah
they obviously have a problem and why
are people missing it can you tell me
that cuz I don't know that's why I'm
asking
see so apparent on UFC unfiltered
podcast shut up to Matt Serra and Jim
Norton love those guys white was asked
if early Wayans were to blame for the
weight problems his fighters have been
having he agree that there's a clear
connection and now it's the promotion's
look at implementing later weigh-ins
again yes I do think it's that and guess
what we're getting rid of it we're
looking at taking the Wayans back to the
way they used to be so when the guys
weigh in there at the ceremonial
weigh-ins that will be it that will be
the real land bro keep [ __ ] read any
faster Jesus Christ
welcome my bad damn bro I know every
teleprompters [ __ ] this day and age on
TV son well chain could have also made
the print a little bit just no justice
like squint what is that a 9 font you
know that Valve Attica yeah
those [ __ ] eyes bro I know and you
know what he's going through
I mean you got him reading at 11 feet
away
I know Rose be like help a brother out
man
I'll bet a good night Alex I pray don't
withdraw but you didn't get all of it
shake the bottle bro
look I've watched some sweat how about
[ __ ] pinion Cass I'm just being crazy on
the chin
dude I'll be just so addicted you just
like brawl I need another bottle I know
there's [ __ ] July done bro let us put
a couple of them up your ass right now
brothers deposits yeah I'll be scared
really want to get hired not bro
straight to the brain row that should've
turn you inside out now yeah your
[ __ ] arms will grow dawg you think
putting that kratom in your [ __ ] tea
in the morning whatever it's fun
put that [ __ ] in your household Cheers
trying you down no high nine grams and
yes [ __ ] arms up bro you'll be able
to hug your whole family away you had a
girl like Bobby [ __ ] dude you you'll
be doing anything you want to do bro
think this is a head butt chance yeah
just something you'll be doing it it'll
be the head-butting you'll be doing it
dude that's what you should do in China
should get a kimono and [ __ ] just
wear sandals and stick kratom up your
[ __ ]
just [ __ ] and go nuts bro what yeah
that sound like going nuts you well go
nuts dude the thing is that whenever you
don't do drugs or alcohol you got to do
crazy [ __ ] I'm saying crazy they say
isn't a drug so you put that [ __ ] you
show everyone your starfish [ __ ] China
you make a bank dude they had this they
had this guy growing up Walter or mr.
Walter people called him but I don't
even know I don't think it matters what
you called him really because he would
he would give us 20 bucks to look at his
[ __ ] from like 40 feet away from
where he is that he had a hairy [ __ ]
oh I don't know I was a kid man I don't
want to make Bank broke
oh I'd make the money we got the money
so you remember so you saw it a few
times but from 40 feet away you can't
see it that good yeah just looks like a
but I hole bro any play brown-eyed girl
on the his car stereo while we do it
how crazy is that damn you're like you
didn't touch your nothing there he
wasn't like that he wasn't brave like
that he was just kind of chill and it's
cash though you do it on Fridays I got
paid or
when did he do it you know when he would
do it he would do it on days whenever we
were kids were supposed to be at school
but there was like parent teacher or
something so all kids were doing like
Labor Day and [ __ ] yeah he do it like
I'm weird days like that when your
parents maybe still had to work but you
like Columbus think you were home yeah
Columbus you know if it's Columbus Day
you're still that man's ask we make you
fall away Oh Oh Julius Slurpees went
over that 20 bucks in 91 Oh bro Paula
now if I if I remember my mom give me
$10 cash sometimes I'd walked up with my
brother to Brunswick is a bowling alley
and I would get french fries from there
now - welcome to 7-eleven and get myself
an ice cold coke for dr. pepper for a
fresca usually a fresca and I would get
fresca and fries bro and then you I do I
could come out the closet Kreskin fries
that's a karthick rule curly fries bro
dude once a minute currently on a
regular fries but uh I want you [ __ ]
curls I think wow sounds like it's not
bro what you do for desserts suck your
own dick by sucking dick hey no you
don't do I could I do a similar and go -
I'd get Doritos right and I'll go to the
nacho cheese I dumped nacho cheese in
the Doritos you never had Doritos with
matches
didn't even have a [ __ ] lift the over
a [ __ ] lid bro - get that starfish
dick you're doing nothing with it you're
doing nothing with it do you have a
Mexican wife and daughter and refuse to
learn Spanish okay but yeah you'll come
home with nacho cheese on your Doritos I
was a kid bro I was nine but you cared
more about assimilating men than you do
now man how's that Mexican Doritos and
nacho cheese's not Mexican there's
something special for Mexican about it
oh wow this race is brought don't think
it is laughs I said I put lime all over
the top of them that would be race it's
called lemo
okay get your [ __ ] family tight bro
jeez hell yeah man you're just being
lazy not making me off that dick what
else you got chin just as a follow-up on
ima one batgirl and really
has a husband who was also her coach has
Nazi tattoos on his arm they just found
everyone just found out recently through
a picture this right here and then uh so
he initially was saying like he would
not cover it up because even though he's
past all that he looks at it as like a
reminder of who he was when he was that
young the line so now after all this
backlash everyone is saying like why
aren't you covering it up
apparently he's saying she's saying that
he'll cover it up if it the tattoo
artists can make you look less trasher
than it is right what do you think all
excuses now what some people reach out
to me on in my DM send them DMS and they
were saying that if you get those and
you cover them up those other people who
are in that group that will find you and
[ __ ] you almost more of us said that
it's more aged well I don't know how to
deal with it but they were saying like
once you're in that Club if you do
disrespect that stuff and they find out
they [ __ ] they come like it's more of a
fear-based thing right which I don't
know if I buy that excuse either I don't
know that underworld you probably do
Theo but uh you gotta cover them up or
just wear long sleeves like a fat kid at
the pool
you can't first of all I know this I
know the gentleman from Louisiana I
believe so you can't wear long sleeves
down there you know you'll die mhm and
uh but second of all if it's part of his
past like what do we get
you know SS and swastika I agree it's he
symbol look I agree it's bad stuff but
here's the thing he probably was a dumb
kid it's why me didn't know anything
about it I bet he knew it had you know
now if he'd know if he's all
anti-semitic 'el and that kind of [ __ ]
that's one thing if he's a dumb kid that
was in a [ __ ] got into a gang because
he'd have any parents in prison
okay join a group any they made him or
you know he felt like he had to do that
to survive but once you cover him as a
grown man right as I like you I have
tattoos and I've had tattoos covered not
because they're racist shits because
they're terrible right and like say if
you had anything I'm that would offend
anyone as a comic or anyone don't you
think you would cover it right so at
this point in life yeah I would I would
get it dusted he's 40 and he's the head
coach of his wife or girl yeah just got
to the UFC and now Devon was talking
about his dumb ass instead of her right
and we're all you gotta do is
and if I'm the UFC I'm not letting them
in corner I'm going you bro you gotta
cover those up and if I'm you Reebok I'm
like we can't give you a fight kit we're
this blank one right yeah we're this uh
yeah we're a [ __ ] ones here's a white
one here's a hood yeah
we're a onesie yeah he should he should
get them adjusted right but I think that
you got to give like you know at least
just understand his story I think there
has to be some understanding of his
story unless he's a [ __ ] anti-semitic
a weirdo then you just can't I feel like
if you leave though there has to be some
you got a touch of racism in you right
if you leave if you continue to leave it
on like that's a good point like there's
something going on okay yeah if you
flaunt them then yeah there's something
going on there which then that goes back
to the if you like anti-semitic oh man
you just can't do that it you can't you
can't just can't I don't I don't look at
that picturing um nah they're not racist
yeah I don't know man but see I'm from
you know I'm from an area like that and
not everybody's racist I'm gonna put two
there swatch good tattoos great point if
I did see somebody with that I'd be like
tattoos hella questionable and what is
SS tattoos Nazis SS what SS the [ __ ]
they call no SS is what they called the
Nazis SS Shu stop fail oh this [ __ ] stop
oh yeah yeah but it stands for Satan is
it that's what I thought your stuff fell
no but there's a the SS it stands for
something [ __ ] and stuff whoa oh wow I
didn't realize all that yeah well if
he's got all of that [ __ ] then man you
gotta tighten up you got to tighten up
if you just cover him Aaron like all
good men but then like I said people or
demon are we going dude it doesn't
really work like they recover him then
he has to worry about a safety well then
and you see then that's why I'd love for
him to say look the reason that I got
these is because this is what was on the
line for me correct I didn't have a
choice
this was in a fit you know and then you
know if you don't understand that who's
not gonna understand that every I feel
like Jewish people would because they
that's what happened to them if he was
like y'all I have to get him for my
safety I listen when in I'd say in
prison there's groups
got to join a group because run your own
you get [ __ ] in the ass yeah so I
signed with the you know with the white
supremacist eiope these tattoos in order
for my protection I'm a grown man now
sure pregame covered but I'm told if I
am covered they're gonna come find me
and [ __ ] up me and my family so I can't
do that either I'm scoring long sleeve
from now on yeah I'm a different man
there you go that's good yeah I like
that I think that that makes sense but I
think he should explore mean I think
there's an opportunity for some learning
here so he should explain that's the
truth who knows if people didn't I'm
gonna tell him the truth he could also
be like look I got I chose to get him at
a town life I didn't even had no idea
what they meant and also other white
supremists like well let's see if he
removed um well he still has them he's
safe with us yeah that's true they have
other race [ __ ] to do but I think that
yeah I think it's a good opportunity for
him if he gave the [ __ ] to shed some
light on some stuff and help people
learn like why people do that kind of
stuff and then also in the end like how
many guys have the harem obviously it's
not racist how many guys have the cobweb
tattoo on their forearm somewhere
because that's usually means you've been
in prison what really what it symbolizes
yeah you didn't mean you were a chimney
suite no no wow it's like it's you know
pretty common man how's the suit go game
are you guys fans of John wick the Keanu
Reeves movie no just part three of our
three star now next year I'll give a
[ __ ] dog died yeah that's and stuff you
can't just blindly hit a group anymore
for no reason no you saw on the Nazis
though yeah well it just makes me think
you can't you just like that's just such
an old idea you know it's like there's
no you know you can't do it
well there's neo-nazis but yeah what
else you got Jim alright let's talk
about jared leto being in a joker movie
all by himself
starring it so that is apparently
confirmed now and there's also another
movie where Joker is it gonna be played
by Joaquin Phoenix and Martin Scorsese
is gonna be directing it so those movie
those both of those movies are coming
out around the same time that's my boys
double Joker movie yeah that's two
different Joker once
Joaquin Phoenix is playing is the
just pure fire my boys the agent for the
directors in that and it's said it's
amazing these boots are made for walking
did all open up a shoe store Milwaukee
oh yeah walking could Joaquin and I'm
off I came to act is a song bro he could
act it if he he could be whatever you
wanted he could be an animal of it I bet
if they let him grow his hair out around
his eyes and over his nose and over his
whole body did you trick you into
thinking he's like a lion an Anna more
like a lion that have been hit by
lightning yeah yeah real actual lion
yeah yeah but people for years we've
like oh yeah we got this endangered long
and he you know he goes by the name of
Jackie and secretly he's winking that
it's walking I can't get enough of a mom
down for jared leto and walking free
astronaut will Joker yeah I'm down let's
have a joker off they should start doing
that with movies where they come out
with two movies the same time suits 20
lines more mmm and we have one of the
winds and the other one has to [ __ ]
go now what they did was spider in right
there's been three version of spider-man
the new one sucks ass
well Tobey Maguire with spider-man to me
as a kid yeah in spider baby I don't
want your [ __ ] swinging around the
city with some [ __ ] silk in love with
a redhead yeah dude that's like every I
mean yeah it you're basically you're
basically just a haberdash and it makes
suits and nobody's still broke
yeah somebody's like a college kid
someday it's like what the [ __ ] yeah the
only super always broke all the time you
can't change your clothes legally in a
phone booth anymore
so there's no I'll do it yeah that's
Superman by here you yeah what some of
they steal each other's like changing my
ideas I love the joke though what does
get you I know their movie coming out
the finishing lasts final Friday is
coming out
you like the Friday's yeah like I can't
get enough of them really I love all
three of them I think is gonna suck dick
yeah I know this one it's way it's way
too late and Tucker's not a part of it
apparently yeah but it's Mike Epps Mike
Epps is yeah oh and the last two so
that's all you care about do Chris
Tucker you know he got famous off the
first Friday and said peace yeah when
did rush hour and kind of blew up yeah
and then he disappeared really you got
thick kind of thick yeah you look like
yeah it's talking about a whole bunch of
bad Chris Tucker yes
you guys talk about that urban sugar wah
that is done by them Hornet that big
dipper's ever been sugar hornets dude
them Hornets with the ABS well black
people do super well with a lot of sugar
you know it's like it's like white
people don't do well a lot of sunlight
it's like everybody has their
arch-nemesis yeah you know white people
in gluten I think yes some we should
late lame white people can't handle
gluten yeah I think I'm off of it you do
yeah yeah you seem like a [ __ ] dude
rolled oats in his [ __ ] cheeks bro
yeah are you a fan of Friday Jim the
first one I loved a first one a second
one's better did I let me go to Rancho
Cucamonga what the cholos in there yeah
third one's great too
I don't like throwing I love the third
one the third one with uh
want these security guards in the third
one there are security guards but that
remember homeboys in it the [ __ ] the
the pimp oh come on famous comedian who
know the small guy pimp pimp oh shoot
okay will ya he's the best he's in this
one he was in the third one he should be
in all of it yeah we have to just be a
reality show
oh and then also who's a homeboy the big
black dude who was saying that he had
sexually harassed the me to movement
some oh yeah rah la with the Larry
Donnell Rawlings no no you're talking
about the Old Spice [ __ ] Old Spice the
Old Spice guy yeah Terry Crews Terry
Crews somebody grabbed his day yeah and
it all the [ __ ] Joey Diaz talked about
that a miss fast oh yeah yeah it's a
great bit but with uh Terry Crews he was
great in that and he's at a prison
that's cradle you want some mistake well
I just noticed there's a bunch of it on
a table a lot of pills I think I don't
know where those came from I think chin
was sniffing them dudes lost a grandma
kid I'll watch it easy I'll watch an
Asian guy did some kratom yeah me too
you know I'd watch that on the YouTube
[ __ ] me we did a bunch of these you
sniff - are you packed them in your lip
like chew or some sitchin sometimes I
think this is gonna be bad though and I
just yeah
dude one of the things I have about
watch it it's televisions to clear these
days you notice that people look busted
you can see their makeup yeah at the HD
it's way too clear
like you lose the the illusion that it's
not real yeah yeah I agree you know and
I don't know why that they haven't
figured out that people don't like it
that clear when you can see it just like
clearer than real life it almost doesn't
seem it doesn't seem fun anymore
yes yeah it doesn't seem funny it's the
frame rates and you know that's why so
proper look the way they look it's just
too clear everyone's moving to normally
yeah like it's your you're in the room
with them people don't like that no I
don't like that yeah and why don't they
realize that that people like I did not
watch Dances with Wolves the other day
in 4k or something dude it looked like
goddamn 4k bro it was it looked like you
know a bunch of people just camping ten
[ __ ] Oklahoma yeah yeah it's okay but
it's too much man yeah it's too much
like I watched some of those sitcoms in
chiton on NBC or ABC and it's I mean you
can tell the makeups chaos for us and
it's all tightly shot now they don't let
anybody really do any acting it's just
like donta I all edited it's all gotten
so bad man that's watchin this one it's
not a baddie ordeal I've got a bounce up
with that to 15 guys when you and I get
on man we go hard in the paint all right
here's the last one this isn't China we
do man this isn't China I was in China
this is for you a crayfish removed this
quad to escape a hotpot but if you look
at it it's not that crazy so I'll show
you real quick it looks like he's being
grabbed right by other crawfish right
then he goes you go screw this I'm gonna
take my own cloth so he takes it off
here Oh many bounces oh wow there's no
other things grabbing himself looks
could be down in that sauce you don't
know what's in this sauce trick hold up
this is a crawdad which a ton of those
huh you suck the heads drinks the tails
mmm
yeah sometimes I'll switch the idea up
to pen right now I'm feeling yeah but
hold on
so he's in that sauce boiling water
right there blowing sauce and he just
ripped his own hand off to get away yeah
maybe it something's wrong with his arm
yeah maybe could feel like the meat
separated from their armies they gotta
get this [ __ ] off I may be a gal you
never know dude I get gout - if I'm in
that big pot of salty water he's on that
kratom
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah babies on that kratom baby
that's that crawl kratom brother
sometimes trying to take your [ __ ] low
to create them and then start playing
the guitar really in the dark and that's
where gar Brooks comes out yeah wrote
ideas let's give chin some creative and
see if he pulls both of his [ __ ] arms
oh dude they had to do with no arms in
my neighborhood growing up used to fight
everybody bro you kick him right like a
flawless cat no he would snatch him in
his neck and then choke him out I've
seen that like a [ __ ] snake Brothers
boy Gert good is that a chin that's it
yeah dude I'm at I'm gonna be in Chicago
- I'm telling you guys now doing
stand-up in Chicago this August 16 17th
and 18th at Laugh Factory that Factory
yeah so I'm excited I'm going to Raleigh
in a few weeks I'm excited about that
you and I are doing a show together oh
yeah I think July 18th yep at Comedy
Store at The Comedy Store do and I may
stack other people on it we'll put other
people on for sure but yeah but we're
gonna go do it it's gonna be fun you
want jobs oh [ __ ] out there the Rat King
definitely the Rat King and the Beast
thing yeah the rat came the be changing
the Rat King putting a Shawn at the
comedy storing your [ __ ] EpiPen Braun
throw them at [ __ ] shower buddies yeah
and also bring your kratom - let's get
let's get loose in that [ __ ] oh dude
robbing [ __ ] onstage him just suck great
him through his [ __ ] I'll do that no
prob he said I'll do my the guitar no
let's just see him pull off one of his
[ __ ] arms there yeah we cool to like
pull off his hand
yeah let's enter in the Miss America
pageant and that's his special talent
takes his hand yeah he swallows to
crater throws his arm leaves in onstage
no yeah be in Chicago the champion
Chicago where else I'm gonna be in
Raleigh coming up in about a month
Toronto I'll be at the Just for Laughs
Film Festival go get those tickets and
uh and pick me is one of the acts you
want to see boys then are you gonna be
are you in town next week yeah I'll be
in town next week I'm going to Oklahoma
this week next week no 15th
fifteen let me see well were you gonna
be you got a show yeah come to a set of
dice house with me
oh really yeah I love that let's do it
brother I love it out there the 15th
I'll be at a dam oh I'll be in Calgary
you making [ __ ] up right now no we'll be
in cow [ __ ] being I ran my bad my will
you know that's what you said
oh [ __ ] I'll be here the 15th and you
look down with yeah I do a segment ah
[ __ ] me I'm in the Congo on a 15 I
thought you meant September dude I'll be
in the Congo I score more kratom for you
freaking creeping out of the trees
though do we she needs that let's get
like a rare element and see if we can uh
put a pill in yeah make it into
something dope like what though I don't
know my god what's up porcupine blood
yeah something that makes your [ __ ]
neck feel real real loose imagine
something that made your neck weak and
yet hold your [ __ ] head up like this
where you're talking to people man but
you're here yeah people like Tim are you
about the full year out no I
[ __ ] my night is done but I feel
good yeah I still want to be a hoe to
[ __ ] pay attention watch this go CTO
next week is the next week in Chicago
August 16 17 to 18 to Calgary this was
not already sold out in Oklahoma this
week Oklahoma works solemn spring I'm a
dog really Bob I'm there July 7th oh
nice I'm slaying some jokes and you
watch the UFC fights with me oh really
yeah dang yeah dude in duels because
they probably got a nice set up there to
watch the fights yeah so I'm doing an
hour stand-up and then I'll chill after
and watch fights with everyone imma
watch some of these fights this weekend
man do it bro let me know what you think
text me yeah let you know I think about
a couple of them let me know dawg
I'll be the Icehouse is the 15th next
Friday there are 20 tickets left at that
show and then the following week June
22nd 23rd I'm at Houston Houston improv
and then after that July 7th it's the
big UFC night so I'll be doing Cherokee
Casino in Oklahoma our stand-up then
I'll watch the fights with you guy
that's one night one show only and then
after on the Spokane Spokane Washington
just rings now chief at kake.com
it's the Rat King and the Beast thank
you guys so much man thanks chin up
Giovana everybody this is the fighter in
the bond I'm out